love this man his podcast 10 questions
with kyle brandt is just taking off so
is his entire career you can watch him
on frogger right here on peacock he also
had a little cup of coffee uh on cbs the
nfl today this past week as well while
game day morning was off he's on good
morning football every single morning on
nfl network at 7 00 a.m eastern time
kyle brandt back here on the show how
you been kyle rich there are many shows
there are many good shows but there is
not a better on-hold show than the rich
eyes the things that i just heard as i'm
sitting here with this phone tommy where
do i even react that you had a caller
basically insinuate that uh brockman was
ben jarvis green ellis i think that's
the patriots yeah
and then i had mariucci wearing a zipper
[ __ ] mask and uh michael irvin saying uh
rich i think marioche is sleeping and
then you put your hand on it and saying
like you better go wake him up then i
mean what am i listening to beautiful
thursday that's right it's a pulp
fiction anniversary we're getting calls
of people with you know large
imaginations oh it's the best what is
that oh my gosh all right let's uh let's
jump in with both feet here uh
you and i were both pounding the table
for justin fields it feels good for me
how does it feel for you right now
well you just mentioned large
imaginations that's what you need to see
at bears win this weekend um
i'll jump in with two feet on this i
want to ask the the media uh nade the
country stop calling bears packers a
rivalry it it's not right now it hasn't
been in a long time there's pageantry
and there's history and tradition but
it's not a rivalry rivalry look it up
you have to have at least some give back
on one side it's the expression the
hammer does not have a rivalry with the
nail we had randall cavan good morning
football this morning rich as part of
your
well-produced intro to bring the guest
on we we stumbled across the fact that
randall cobb is 13 and two against the
pairs which is one of those things where
you say rich and you say you're like
well that can't be right i'll have to
just trust the researcher oh no it's
right and um aaron rodgers may not have
another time in soldier field who knows
this might be the last one as they call
it lambo south but
i'm just going to be completely honest
they are a bunch of revenants and the
fact that they kill bears every single
time they come out jordy nelson's got a
necklace full of bear claws randall cobb
does aaron rodgers does and justin's
field is supposed to be the end of that
thing um if he wins this game they will
change soldier field to field field
that's how big of a deal that would be
it would be that big of a deal because
what about him actually laying down his
uh calling card this way what happens if
that happens i mean that is that is
possible
kyle i know you said you know you're
joking about an imagination i mean
that there's there's no reason why uh
the bears defense can't play as well or
close to in the area code of what the
saints did in week one against you know
aaron rodgers that that week one
you know disaster that's been already
discarded
uh wasn't just because
everyone was like well rogers didn't
care and they were sleepwalking and so
on and so forth i mean the saints had
something to do with it bears have the
ability to do something like that don't
they well i think you brought up
something that's not mentioned and
because all of the heat and all of the
eyeballs go to matt nagy and justin
fields and andy dalton meanwhile the the
monsters of the midway the 2021 chicago
bears lead the nfl in stacks and that
includes that's the team that went
against another team to give up nine
sacks in one game the browns it's not
the browns it's not your undefeated
cardinals it's none of those teams it's
the bears and all of a sudden khalil
mack is the best player on the team and
he hasn't been for three years and he's
kind of just this great physical force
that draws double teams and doesn't run
up stats he's amazing so listen they
here's the problem they will give you
the occasional packer win this era of
bears football and the trubisky bears
with khalil mack did beat rogers once on
their way to an nfc north title it's
just that's the one that keeps you
coming back and if i sound like a
self-loathing chicagoan
it's because years of that rich they
call it they call chicago's second city
it's not because of new york their
second city to green bay wisconsin
that's just the way that it's been since
i was in eighth grade and my dad said to
me you know once this bastard farm
retires then we can finally beat this
game no sorry dad after far retired a
serial killer who wears number 12 came
in for the next 16 years and i'd be
willing to bet that when he leaves
jordan love is going to be joe montana
kyle brandt of good morning football and
ten questions with kyle brandt podcast
and the ringer in spotify right here on
the rich eisen show how do you see
tonight playing out thursday night
football walk me through this one i did
um something i call heavy lifting uh on
the air this morning which i i chalked
up my hands and i put on that old 1980s
lou ferrigno leather weight lifting belt
and i put the the the dumbbells up uh
with the eagles logos on them and um
i would love nothing more than the fact
that jalen hurts would go insane tonight
and because people are digging up these
incredible stats about him and that he's
got one of the greatest starts
statistically in history in the super
bowl era and he can run and he can pass
he only has a couple of wins and there's
a there's there's things that i that
eagles fans and our staff will tell us
that did you know that jalen hurts has
had five touchdown passes that have been
brought back this season because of dumb
penalties and illegal touching and
linemen down field so i don't think the
eagles are going to win i think for them
to win i think it needs to be the jalen
hurts national coming out party where he
has 450 total yards and brady throws a
couple of picks i just don't this eagles
team i think they're so fun and
energetic and i actually like the vibe
from siriani because he's a little out
over his skis and he's a little nuts and
that's my kind of guy
but uh i heard brady on a short week of
something like 11 and two or something
insane and i i think there's too much
firepower well i mean we were we started
the show here today kyle with um
remembering it was october 8th 2020 and
here we are on what the 13th 14th of
october in 2021 uh and it was on october
8th 2020 when nick foles in soldier
field on a thursday night beat tom brady
who held up the number four and we were
all talking about the senior moment for
getting the number of downs and can
brady really do it outside of new
england i mean certainly after he threw
a pick six against new orleans in week
one and you know and he's right around
500 dropped him to three and two and and
how laughable once again
all of those suppositions about the
diminishing returns and looking for it
from tom brady the number of times that
we've seen that in a 44 year old it is
just
off the hook
what we're seeing from him is he enters
tonight's contest to kick off week six
is number one in passing yards and so
many other passing categories yeah and
he he may be number one in the mvp
category too here's my beef right now um
i sense a fatigue
in the fan base and in the media of of
brady and it kind of reminds me rich of
a meryl streep type deal where oh what
do you know meryl got nominated again
lottie no no no no don't give me the
whole we're running out of things to say
about tom brady that is your job as a
wordsmith and or writer to come up with
new ways to talk about brady and i'm
bending over backwards every day to do
it because i will not let the season go
by watching a guy born in the mid 70s
who's going to lead the league in pass
and get overlooked i looked it up for a
44 year old american man in 2021 the
american heart association says if you
can do 15 push-ups 15 push-ups you're
doing great you're in shape you got your
body together just 15 push-ups tom brady
has 15 touchdown passes in the nfl
against 22-year-old athletes looking to
take his head off it's absolutely
incredible so i'm piling on here rich my
son came up to me seven years old he's
never said this to me before he said
daddy i want a jersey i'm like oh great
step into my office he says who do you
think i should get i said well i think
you should get someone who's a great
player and a great person there's so
many to choose from do you want a justin
herbert or patrick mahomes josh allen
lamar jackson he says let me talk to my
friends he goes to school comes back the
next day he says i want a tom brady
jersey is it kevin you know what tom
brady jersey he's older than daddy i
don't care he wants it he's into it and
this is in new york the kids in new york
are saying mahomes josh allen no give us
the tom brady jersey it's insane and i
won't stand for the fatigue from the
media i agree with you well put well
said and well sourced right there
straight from a seven-year-old and he
goes
so what is he in like second grade third
grade to start second grade so the rest
of the second graders get around and so
they're they're talking about tom brady
like second graders did you know uh you
know
well i guess those second graders are
now
in the job market right those second
graders when brady started you know
getting second graders wanting his
jersey it's
we'll never see anything like it again
man we we won't cause he's not he's not
having any diminishing returns as a
matter of fact
uh the the things that counted against
him last year new place new offense just
getting trying to figure out with his
teammates that's all done that's that's
over and he won a super bowl in that
transition period
that's why i think there's still the
team to beat despite four and one teams
even in dallas
you know and and the and the
uh cardinals being undefeated at some
point someone's gonna have to come at
the king in the king's house where he
won the super bowl and they're gonna
have to beat him that's gonna help and i
know that look the rams took care of
business and that's exciting and
everything but
it is truly the biggest story still and
and i understand like we've been talking
about him so long and he's so good that
there is this thing where you're like
well look at all these other shiny
objects let's talk about herbert and
josh no no no hold on the biggest story
we asked the question the other day rich
it was
if brady wins mvp this year and at 44
years old is it the greatest
accomplishment of his career and he
started throwing around well you know he
won them back to back he went three out
of four he came back from 28 to three
i think it's not even close in fact i
think the greatest accomplishment of his
career was the win he had last week
against the dolphins because he did it
at 44 years old and it'll be this week
when he does it tonight every single
game is the greatest accomplishment of
his career until he runs down george
bland it was 48 and i think he might
well another accomplishment is that he
got a
a seven-year-old in the suburbs of new
york city wanting his jersey
at age 14. the second graders at at my
son's school what are they supposed to
do rich get jets or giants jerseys come
on now what which one would have really
made you a uh a little piece of you die
though i mean if he came back with were
you i mean you asked your son to
crowdsource it and you knew the answer
would have to be purchased
yeah i i heard there was a rumor that my
son was going to come back and be like i
don't know
daddy i'm looking at this as a long-term
investment and i've heard there's this
young quarterback named jordan love for
the packers it was a bright future can i
get a number 10 package
thank god
so it's it would be
but what would it
which is
more disturbing to you the fact that
it's a packer the fact that it's a poor
football decision currently
or a bad investment which one would it
be
for you i i think uh i think probably
the poor football decision you know
they're still i i can't shake that
jordan love pick rich
someone was saying the other day i'm
trying to remember who it was someone
who was with was on our show they were
saying
listen the roethlisberger situation
that's why you take jordan love that's
why the packers look smart i just won't
stand for it i will never think that was
a good pick i still think it cost them a
super bowl because they were a player
short against tampa last year and i just
can't get into it so no i won't abide by
it but i know there's still takes on
that before i let you go kyle brent
speaking of investments uh the wall
streeters uh
gambit that you and schrager do is just
of hilarious i mean
the fact and my uh susie my wife sent me
the return of the wall streeters that
that's how i first saw it she she uh
texted it to me and uh have you uh
attempted to ask dicaprio to cameo in
something like that
has that has that has that play has that
card even
played couple years ago we got the great
jim cramer to cameo right and he came in
and jared and trent were doing their
things and all of a sudden jim cramer
just walked into the set and started
talking about the eagles right but it's
i think that could be a stepping stone
to dicaprio
mostly leo dicaprio likes to do his
movies and he likes to talk about global
warming and god bless him yes but if we
could get him to come in with jared and
trent i think we could really bring the
house down that would be it right you'd
have to retire after that right or who
else could we get like bud fox get sheen
you know like i don't know who else who
else can we get cameo
character and boiler room you do that uh
that keys to a car it's a ferrari costs
about two hundred thousand dollars like
that is the kind of guy who jared and
trying to have posters up in the wall
yes i am liquid
oh yeah yeah i'm liquid yeah you got to
always refer to your liquid yeah
we do it rich i think well that's the
last time we're ever doing that
just like some of the one-liners though
are just incredible
i don't rock a watch i wear a timepiece
yeah uh i mix uh i mix creatine with my
martinis
it's the nuances that make it fun it's
not enough to say i once hooked up with
the bridesmaid at my own wedding you got
to say
i hooked up with the bridesmaid at my
last wedding
little things like that to just make you
so insufferable and it's so fun my
favorite parts of it too is you and
schrager doing your thing right and the
new yorkers don't bat an eyelash you
just keep walking they just keep walking
just like here you go there's a camera
crew and you two guys i mean you're
stalking the stream okay you're doing
nothing but just stalking up and down
the street you know strutting around
hardly just maybe barking out one word
guttural but new yorkers just walk
across the street and just look at you
and just keep going
zero security no barricades it's full
gorilla we're just standing there on an
open street and part of the game within
the game for me is i'm trying to get a
new yorker to even look at me snack to
me and i'm screaming you know wake up
new york and like no one will even look
at me
it's amazing any other town if see
something say something and there's a
swat team there new yorker will not look
up from their phone or their newspaper
to even give you eye contact and that's
kind of the beauty
so uh before you go uh kyle dive into
your your pop culture um acumen here it
is the 27th anniversary of pulp fiction
your favorite scene in pulp fiction is
which which one do you choose uh rich in
the year of our lord 1994 i was 15 years
old i saw the movie pulp fiction seven
times in the theater seven times wow
because i wanted to memorize every
single word it is still the
big kahuna burger scene in which jules
and vincent go into the apartment with
frank whaley and flocka seagulls on the
couch and uh the first time that sam
jackson and i will strike down upon thee
with great vengeance and furious anger
those who attempt to poison and destroy
my brothers and you will know my name is
the lord when i lay my vengeance upon
thee it's the best
well done i thank you thank you very
much it is it was i do remember seeing
that for the first time that that
opening scene that you're referring to
was shocking and also so laugh out loud
hilarious enjoyable and frightening at
the same time i remember sitting there
going i've never felt this way
you know like scorsese movies are
frequently frightening and laugh out
loud hilarious at the same time that
that i'd never been made to feel that
way outside of a scorsese movie that
opening scene did grab me like that and
the [ __ ] scene as well
i'm serious is is another disturbing yet
hilarious on occasion
and you're wondering why am i laughing
while watching some of the most horrific
um you know language and uh you know um
action in my entire life but to me i i i
named that just off the top of my head
as my favorite scene and then i
remembered the walking watch soliloquy
is just the that's it that was that just
that two and a half minutes or three
minutes soliloquy
that would that's it for me that's my
favorite
tour de force
rarely is there a one scene appearance
in any movie that's that powerful and he
just keeps going this watch and then he
he held this uncomfortable hunk of mask
and then he died of dysentery but it
it's just so good it's so perfect
kyle thanks for the time we'll chat
again soon the best thanks guys
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here